[exciting rock music plays]
Ever since I was a kid,
I've always wanted to be a criminal.
If I could've put it in my yearbook,
I'd have put, "I wanna be a criminal."
Things have changed. Nowadays
you gotta figure out some sort of way
to finesse the system.
My name is Raymond Trapani,
Chief Operating Officer of Centra Tech.
Our pitch to the world was that
we were gonna create a debit card
where you'd be able to spend
your cryptocurrency in real time.
- It's an electronic money.
- Something about bitcoins or something.
I was all about Centra Tech.
"Look at this, this makes sense."
Just watching something become
extremely valuable, it's like a drug.
[Ray] Tons of money just starts
flooding in, 100,000, another 100,000.
It was probably the most exciting thing
I ever experienced in my life.
[Ray] We didn't know
a thing about this business,
but it didn't matter at all.
It was too easy.
[phone ringing]
[beeps]
[man 1] Ray, Visa's just saying
this company Centra is not allowed
to issue a card with "Visa" on it.
[Ray] I-- I know--
I know details about that.
I-- I can't give you
direct answers on that.
- [intriguing music plays]
- [man 1] It just didn't make sense.
Things looked funny.
[man 2] They have nothing.
So the whole thing is to now make
themselves as legitimate as possible.
[man 3] It was very suspicious.
I started noticing that
things were changing on their website.
[man 1] The pictures didn't even
look like real people.
[man 3] I researched the founders.
Wow, the CEO is actually
Raymond's grandfather.
[man 4] There was an aspect to Centra
that was really brazen.
We are 100% not a scam.
No one ever says that
unless it's actually a scam.
[laughs]
[man 2] This shady company
just graduated to the next level.
[man 4] They started taking actions
to try and hide things.
Money started going out of accounts.
[man 1] Somebody needs to figure out
what the hell is going on here.
[man 3] I took a considerable loss.
[man 5] Obviously,
something was not right.
[man 6] It's like giving a middle finger
to the FBI.
[man 7] He's a real criminal.
[man 8] Ray's a piece of ****.
[man 3] Absolutely wanted
to take them down.
[man 9] This guy's a fraudster.
[music crescendoes, ends]